[Music]  gwl is back kinda and not here as of  today there's a brand new channel by  Wendover productions and it's called  half is interesting the videos are about  half as long and probably about half as  good as the ones here it's essentially  the continuation of the old twl series  without the restriction of only picking  topics from that Wikipedia list there's  no more waiting because the first video  is up now and it's about what's the  longest drivable distance on earth  videos will be going up there weekly  every Thursday at 10:30 a.m. Eastern  Wendover productions will remain just as  it always has the only difference is  that you can go listen to more and more  of this voice over there I'd really  appreciate it if you go over there and  subscribe to at least give it a try for  a few episodes I've been putting a lot  of work into developing that channel and  hopefully it will end up being something  great  [Music]